great so the next speaker is silvan
and i think silvan uh doesn't need an
introduction to basically anyone here
but i'll um i'll do my best so um
sylvan is a research engineer at hugging
face and he's one of the core
maintainers of transformers and the
developer behind hugging pace accelerate
and he likes making model training more
accessible and building many of the sort
of fundamental tools that we use like
the trainer for example that we
explained today
and a little personal comment sylvan was
actually a great inspiration to me
because i read your blog post about how
you went on this journey from becoming a
kind of math uh teacher or um in france
and kind of self-taught yourself how to
do deep learning with fast ai and then
working with jeremy and uh this uh this
story is really cool and i think people
should read this to get a sense of like
how you can really break into this field
with a ton of hard work but um
it really really encouraged me because i
came from a different field myself and
it was nice to see that as possible
thanks
so silvan's going to talk to us today
about supercharging your pi torch
training route loop with hugging face
accelerate so let me just add
the
[Music]
file hi everyone i'm silva i'm a
research engineer at tagging face and
today i'm here to talk to you about our
library accelerate
this is a library built on top of by
torch to make training on any kind of
distributed setup as easy as possible
while letting you retain full control
over your training loop
this is super convenient when you want
to implement a training tweet but is not
supported by the trainer api but you
still want to run your script on several
gpus or ntps
for this talk i've written a small
script that fine-tunes the birth model
on the glucolate data set to go over it
quickly i load the data set using the
urging phase datasets library proposes
it by tokenizing everything
load my pretrained model
create a data collateral that will pass
the examples dynamically to the longest
one in each patch
create my training and validation data
loaders
my optimizer
a learning rate scheduler then go over a
traditional pytorch training loop with
an evaluation at each epoch
i can launch my training script quite
easily but what if i now want to launch
it on several gpus at the same time
this is going to require a few changes
in my code let's have a look at why
let's say we have four gpus
on each gpu we are going to load a
different batch of data but we'll go
through our model
and we'll get a loss for that batch
this will allow us to compute the
gradients different on each gpu
we then average those gradients across
all the gpus before performing the
optimizer step
this way the model which was copied on
all gpus stays the same on each gpu
during the wall training
on this slide everything colored in blue
is the same on the four gpus while the
boxes in pink indicate objects that are
different on each gpu
in terms of code here is what we first
need to add to a script
first it needs to accept a new argument
called local rank that will indicate the
index of the process launched
then we have to initialize the torch
distributed environment and set up the
device using that local rank
lastly we need to wrap the model in a
distributed data parallel container
which will be responsible for the
average across processes of the
gradients we saw on the previous slide
this part was easy enough the main
challenge is to make sure our data is
then built exactly the same way on each
gpu
we need to launch the training script on
each gpu
each one of the script will execute the
same operations and we need to give the
same results
your data set needs to be prepared
exactly the same way on each of those
processes
it looks easy said like this but some
operations like converting a list into a
set to remove duplicates are not
deterministic
this means that if you use such an
operation for instance to generate your
labels you may have your labels ordered
differently on each gpu
then you may need to make sure the
training data is traveled the same way
on each process
otherwise each gpu might look at data
another gpu has already tweaked it
only then can you have reliable batches
to send to your model
in terms of code this require all of
those changes just replace the shuffle
equal draw line we used in our training
data loader
into something that will work properly
for distributed training
now that we have those changes ready we
need to launch our training on gpus
by torch provides a launcher for this so
you can type this command python minus m
dot distributed dot launch
minus n proc per node the number of gpus
you have two here
the name of the training script followed
by the arguments to your script
the script launches properly and starts
training
but note that if we try to execute it
like a regular python script it will
fail
if we want to train on tpus we'll need
additional changes compared to the
distributed training on several gpus the
device changes we need to wrap the
training data order in some parallel
loader and rather change the optimizers
to step line which needs to become
xm.optimizer step optimizer
launching the script to the district
launcher with so before would then fail
we need a special launcher for tpus and
of course launching the script like a
regular python script fails again
if we wanted to use mixed precision
training which i won't detail here you
need to add even more lines of code to
the original training script
it will then run properly on gpu but
will fail on cpu
in general adding support for any new
training technique will require you to
learn a lot about that given technique
and add lines to your code that will
then make your script stop working on a
simple setup and make debugging super
hard
accelerate has been created to solve
that problem
by learning one new api that requires a
few changes to your script you then get
something you can run on all kinds of
distributed setup which also supports
mixed precision training or advanced
techniques like zero data parallelism or
zero offload developed by deep speed
the changes to your training loop are
kept to a bare minimum you need to
import a new object called accelerator
instantiate it at the beginning of your
training script then send all your main
objects modal optimizer data orders to
the prepare method of that
accelerator the last line to change is
the lusted backward line which needs to
become
accelerator.backward loss
using accelerates also allows you to get
rid of the device placement lines as the
library will automatically handle that
for you
it also makes it easy to implement
distributed evaluation which we didn't
even start showing in the previous
examples
you just need to gather the prediction
on labels across all gpus when you want
to use them to compute your metric
to then launch your script there are a
few utilities added by accelerate
first
you can set up a configuration by typing
accelerate config
this will pop up a few questions you
need to answer
once it's finished a config is stored in
your cache by default in
your home directory dot cache slash
erginface accelerate
you can then use accelerate launched
followed by the name of your training
script and all the arguments
but your script can still be launched as
a regular python script if you need to
debug it works regardless of whether you
have a gpu or not
you can use accelerate launch to launch
your script on several gpus or on tpus
you can still use the torches within
launcher instead of accelerate launch if
you prefer
all in all with just learning one new
api which added four new lines of code
your custom training loop can now run on
any kind of distributed setup
now if you are in a notebook and want to
launch a distributed training for
instance on collab accelerate comes with
a launcher you can use there aren't any
tpu is available at the time i was
shooting this video
so i'm using a machine with two gpus
instead
the main thing to remember is that you
should put all the parts of the code
that concern objects that will go on
multiple devices gpus or tpu cores in
one big training function
you can have a look at your data set
outside of this training function but
the model the data loaders your
optimizer and the accelerator should all
be defined inside
here my training function is very
similar to the script i just showed you
the only difference is that i'm not
using arc paths and set all my upper
parameters in a cell
if you have executed any instructions
that initializes cuda or python xla you
will need to restart your notebook or
get an error for instance here we ask
for the number of gpus at the very top
and when trying to launch our training
function the launcher failed because
cuda was already initialized
restarting and not executing the first
cell will make everything work smoothly
we can see the training function is
launched twice as many of the logs are
duplicated
before the training starts
since i added a few lines to only
display the progress bar on print on
main process the training logs only
appear once
this concludes my presentation of the
accelerate library i hope you enjoyed it
and that will give accelerate a try the
next time you need to use a custom
trending loop if it doesn't work as
expected please let us know on the
forums or on github
awesome
thanks a lot for that super detailed
video and really nice transitions you
like the adobe premiere pro
thank you
it makes my poor version of just a
collab notebook i feel very inferior
um so i think we have time for one
question
um and the question might be like
you know on the space of like
training models we have things like the
trainer we have accelerate and there's
also some other frameworks that people
can use
um what kind of decisions would you
think about like when should i use
accelerate versus the trainer or
something else for example like if i'm
using like tensorflow does it work with
accelerate that kind of stuff
sure great question um so my my advice
is always to to say that if you just
want to quickly function the model to
see uh like what kind of results you can
get
uh or if you
on your in your data set and in your
task you should just use the
the in-phase trainer or if you are using
tons of care as that fit
because that's gonna just work and you
will give you'll get results without
needing to to go under how to train a
model with pie touch
uh in just a few minutes uh if you know
if you want to try a specific training
trick
then that's where accelerate was
specifically designed because those
objects like the trainer once you want
to to change a little thing like you
should in your talk for instance to use
a custom loss you have to learn like how
it works internally you have to learn
the methods uh to that you need to to
subclass so when you're there it's
actually i think more useful to just go
back to a training loop and and
supercharge it with accelerators if you
need distributed training
and if you it doesn't work with
tensorflow it's specifically built on
top of python for tensorflow you'll need
to
to go to a manual training loop in terms
of
um
but yeah that's pretty much
my advice
cool and then maybe just a very quick
last one which i've asked the other uh
library developers
what's on the roadmap for accelerate
what are the kind of things you're
interested in working on
so yeah a lot in uh is another roadblock
for for accelerate uh we have a few
improvements to the existing uh for
instance the speed integration could be
made a little bit better so we're going
to work on that
and then we also add a
new utility to to make it easier to have
checkpoint directly inside the
accelerate for now you still need to
separately save your model
your your randomness generator states or
all the optimized state or the new great
schedule state so we're going to build
one nice utility function that does all
of that for you and upload them to the
aging facehub and so that you can resume
your training from any machine super
easily with just one layer of code for
accelerate
awesome for next